Sarah Mardini is relieved to be back with
her college classmates in Berlin.
The Syrian refugee and activist was released
on bail after spending more than three months
in a Greek prison.
Sarah was returning from Lesbos in August
when police arrested her.
She had spent the summer volunteering on the
Greek island with a pro-refugee organization.
Because of her work helping migrants, authorities
charged her with people smuggling, money laundering
and espionage.
She now faces a prison sentence of up to 25
years.
"I never regret anything I have done and I
know deep inside that I have done that because
I wanted to help people and that’s given
me motivation."
Her arrest wasn’t the first time that Sarah
made headlines.
She caught the world’s attention in 2015
- but for very different reasons...
She and her sister Yusra were making the perilous
sea crossing from Turkey to Lesbos when their
dinghy began to take on water and sink.
Being experienced swimmers, they jumped overboard
and pulled the waterlogged boat to the shore.
By doing so, they saved the lives of the 18
people on board.
They then began a new life in Germany.
Yusra became a goodwill ambassador for the
United Nations and was on the refugee swimming
team at the 2016 Rio Olympics.
Sarah won a scholarship to study social sciences
in Berlin - but she kept on returning to Lesbos
to help others.
"I believe when you fear something, you should
just go for it.
I fear the place that I landed in, and I wanted
to be on this ground again."
Following Sarah's arrest, her college and
classmates campaigned for her release -- organizing
protests in Berlin, Boston, Athens and other
cities.
Her defense team is calling for greater protection
for humanitarian workers.
"The European Union, this is an ongoing conversation
right now, has to recognize the criterion
of financial benefit as an obligatory requirement
in order to establish the crime of migrant
smuggling.
You cannot have smugglers without benefits
and this is obvious.
You have to exclude from sanctions people
and organizations that provide humanitarian
aid."
Until such safeguards are in place, Greek
authorities can claim that Sarah was helping
migrants enter the country illegally.
She is currently waiting for her case to go
to trial.
She hopes it won't go that far, but is determined
to prove her innocence - and that saving lives
is not a crime.